why London why now well underway now I
think that you know the food scene in
London at first is amazing there's so
much going on there it's so much growing
and a lot there's a lot of talent - a
lot of talent a lot of great quality
product and it's always exciting to
reach out to a different part of the
world now you know you're up as more
croissants than we do it also have
doughnuts so what makes you think the
cronut will take off like it did in New
York City well you know I think the cone
it's just a part of our offering like we
have so many other products so many
other pastries that are as creative as
exciting for London and it is something
that I really focus on is to push for
creativity and to make sure that we are
a different kind of bakery in your
expansion efforts you know with if we
talk about the balance between brand
recognition the desire to protect your
brand and growing the business how do
you balance those two things what I
think it's important that first you are
to look at what we do every day which is
like saving saving food to customers
like giving them a good experience I
think in a bakery it's an everyday
business at first I'm very conservative
and you know I'm very mindful of our
expansion for the business we open a
shop in Tokyo last year and it's doing
amazing this is our first shop in a EU
in London and we're excited to be able
to be a part of the food scene there
what else comes next where do you think
there's gonna be a big appetite for
cronuts
I think what's next the customers will
tell like we are always push myself to
be creative to come up with new ideas
and fun ideas and it's always exciting
for not only for me for my staff but
also for my customers so what's next
people people will tell Domonique you've
brought some things with you there
purely for display purposes I have to
say because we're here we're a
journalistic endeavor here so tell us
what we have here and what you might be
inventing for London in particular so
this this is one right here it's called
the DK it's a flicky camel actually have
one of a best-seller in New York and
also in Tokyo and I think it will be as
well in in London it has nice crispy
outside flicky and understand
it's beautiful for breakfast and the
other one next to it's called the cookie
shop so it's a chocolate-chip cookie
shape as shot glass and we pour fresh
form milk inside and we drink the milk
and eat the cookies stop stop right
there let me ask you how you compete
with other pastry chefs in the likes of
London good Jesus you said the scene is
amazing it's amazing in New York - do
you need to have some kind of I don't
want to call it a gimmick but something
to catch the imagination because you
can't overcharge right yeah I don't
think it's about gimmick getting it so
hard to have your own personality and to
have your own style like if we
restaurant it's different there's over
25,000 restaurants in New York City
they're all so different the style of
cooking the atmosphere in the restaurant
the food they serve like everything is
different I think it's same for a bakery
you have to have your own personality
and you have to make sure that you
connect with the customers
Dominique much as I'm salivating over
what you've just shown us there there is
a big move just now a lot of companies
struggling because sugar has kind of
become the new evil in the diet world
does that pose any risk to the cronut
well you know like if you talk about
sugar you talk about like large company
that sells candies it doesn't affect
small bakeries which which we are were
small bakery we're deli business and
people come for coffee and pastries so
which is not something that will hurt
anyone two things lines are they good do
you deliberately want lines outside your
restaurants we don't deliberately like
keep lines outside our shops a
decent-size we get love customers we
have to treat the volume it's important
to give people for me to give them a
good customer service and experience so
we actually are very nice to the line
every day we give them like fresh-baked
Madeleine's hot chocolate Oh
extra goodies we don't have any time
left but do you have any concerns about
brexit going into London at a time not
right now I think it will eventually you
know like it's not it won't effect a
small business like like ours we're
opening a small bakery in
in London and I don't think you'll have
any effect on us